two weeks ago I told you that this KGB
source for the Donald Trump blackmail
dossier was found dead that was former
Russian KGB chief Oleg eruv in Caen
found dead in the back of his own car
under suspicious circumstances connected
to the Trump blackmail file as a
possible source of former mi6 agent
Christopher's feel and now it continues
Russian opposition journalist bladimir
Kara Mirza Jr who works for an
organization called open Russia which
promotes democracy and human rights in
Russia is all of a sudden suffering from
quote severe intoxication by an unknown
substance according to open Russia
apparently poisoned what is kara Mirza
known for writing books about reforming
Russian government uncovering Russian
political corruption and working with
the u.s. to do so being closely allied
with Boris Nemtsov an outspoken critic
of Vladimir Putin who was fatally shot
just yards from the Kremlin a couple of
years ago kara Mirza was hospitalized on
februari second he collapsed he's now
unconscious in critical condition on
life support with a ventilator at a
Moscow hospital and this is part of the
trend that I've told you about of
Russian dissidents of different types
being mysteriously harmed by unknown
assailants and very very weird
circumstances this is not the first time
that Kara Mirza has been poisoned he was
also poisoned back in 2015 having the
same symptoms he was given a five
percent chance of living by doctors at
the time and coincidentally Yeah right
kara Mirza has been denouncing Russia's
escalation in Ukraine recently russian
federal law enforcement are not
investigating the matter they don't even
seem to be taking it seriously the
russian federal government acted the
exact same way when Kara Mirza was
poisoned the first time and this is a
possible test for the trump
administration with regard to whether
they'll inquire about this or even
mention it critics of putin who were
murdered or died mysteriously I will
remind you starting with as I mentioned
opposition politician boris nemtsov who
was fatally shot outside the kremlin in
20 15 that's number one going further to
billionaire boris berezovsky who was
found dead in his home in 2013 there was
human rights lawyer stanislav markelov
and journalists anastasia babbar ova who
were fatally shot by a masked gunman
near the kremlin in 2009 there was
lawyer sergei magnitsky who was killed
while in Russian police custody in 2009
journalist Natalia esta merova who was
kidnapped and killed by an unknown
perpetrator in 2009 journalist Anna
Politkovskaya who was murdered in her
home by hit men in 06 FSB whistleblower
alexander litvinenko who famously was
poisoned by FSB agents in 2006 American
journalist Paul club Nick oov who was
murdered in his Russian office by an
unknown perpetrator in 2004 and
politician sergey yushchenko who was
murdered by an unknown perpetrator in
two thousand three hours after he
registered his new political party for a
parliamentary parliamentary election all
Pat outspoken dissidents or
whistleblowers all coincidence I'm sure
yeah they certainly have a long history
of doing this and while I don't think
these two recent attacks really give any
veracity to the claims made in the Trump
Russia dossier they certainly come
across as supporting evidence like these
people have to be silenced from saying
anything further it's all part of the
same broader picture that's what matters
and even if we're not drawing specific
connections between every single thing
here we have a very clear picture Russia
yeah what else can I say today's episode
of the David Pakman show is made
possible in part by Warby Parker I
glasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right-wing conspiracy website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five day home try-on from warby
parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not where
wearing contact lenses I started with
the free at home trial they send you
five pairs of glasses you see which ones
you like you send them back and
whichever one you pick they will put
your prescription into I like this
because I can actually show the glasses
to other people and not have to just
decide on the spot like an an eyeglass
store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
three hundred dollars for prescription
glasses with Warby Parker they started
just 95 bucks mine cost that including
lenses and for every pair sold they give
a pair to someone in need so to try the
five pairs and support the david pakman
show go to Warby Parker trial com /t DPS